death of George Floyd has reignited a
nationwide efforts remove statues of
Confederate leaders and slave owners in
Kentucky Friday crews started the
process to remove the statue of
Confederate President Jefferson Davis
from the Capitol rotunda and the change
is not just in the u.s. in London many
monuments to British slave owners are
now at the center of a national debate
as empty as tyub reports some protesters
feel it's long overdue britain's slave
trading past came crashing into the open
as this statue was being dragged through
the streets few were aware of the
atrocities committed by Edward Colson
until the monument to the 17th century
slave trader was thrown into Bristol
Harbor by anti-racism protesters it's an
uncomfortable truth about historic
figures immortalized across the UK in
steel and stone that Oxford University
is also being forced to confront
protesters are demanding this statue of
Cecil Rhodes be removed from one of its
colleges the British imperialist
policies on racial segregation led to
the establishment of apartheid in South
Africa octave is OSG says it can no
longer be ignored
I believe that this statue is a symbol
justice and cross the reminder of what
the UK the US France and all the other
empires have taken from our black
communities while some monuments are
coming down others are being protected
Winston Churchill's statue outside
Parliament is now encased in a metal box
over concerns that will be two-faced
again although to many he's the great
wartime prime minister who defeated the
Nazis to others his well-documented
racism led to atrocities sparking a
fierce debates about who to memorialize
in a nation that rarely confronts its
imperialist past his academic and
activist Patrick Byrne in all the major
cities London Liverpool Bristol were
based on slave money so it's it's
possible history which unfortunately
people don't talk about for a very long
time I've never had as proper debate
about Britain's pass a debate that's now
impossible to ignore for CBS this
morning Saturday in theist hired London